I know from looking at number files how
many of the viewers comment all the time
about the brown paper that you use so I
thought it'd be appropriate to introduce
the brown numbers this is short but
sweet and I think it could be a
challenge for the mathematically
inclined numberphile viewers it's really
straightforward Brown numbers are a pair
of numbers a pair of integers okay which
will let's call them m and n but they
have a very special property their
property is the following that n
factorial plus 1 must equal M Squared
let me just remind you what a and n
factorial is for example 5 factorial is
1 times 2 times 3 times 4 times 5 so n
factorial is just doing that up to be
integer n okay so that's it that defines
my Brown number it's it's a pair of
integers M&MS such that n factorial plus
1 is M Squared let me just show you a
couple so 5 & 4 okay that's my m and n
let's just let's check it so 4 factorial
n is 4 plus 1 well that's equal to 24
plus 1 which is 25 which is 5 squared
another one is 11 and 5 let me give you
another one Brady because you know so 5
factorial plus 1 is equal to what's 5
factorial wealth is 4 factorial is 24 5
factorial is 24 times 5 which is a
hundred and 20 plus 1 that's 121 and
that's the 11 squared
okay so M is 11 so that's why that will
work so let's show you another one
another pair is 71 and 7 all right and
you can go through the same thing if you
work out 77 factorial as one that turns
out to be 71 squared I've shown you
three yeah
that's it that's all there is that's all
there are that's it in fact one of the
greatest mathematicians of the 20th
century
Pollard osh has actually conjectured
that there are only three and that and
that because what that we won't get any
more and so the puzzle of the challenge
I thought was oh he's so simple right
just go and try and find sir
so if Paul Erdos conjectures that there
were no more yeah what does that mean
he's just said well it's not proven no
there's no proof of it that not that I'm
aware of it he must have some very good
reason for conjecturing it and I doubt
that it was that he's literally gone
through every single integer although he
worked as he worked that hard he could
well have there are great stories about
air - quite a character who for many
many years he was effectively homeless
he didn't have a home and what he would
do is he would show up at the his
collaborators house knock up with his
back of claws knock on their door and
and say when they answered it say is
your mind open and that was it and they
would collaborate with him on
mathematics and he would stay with them
and then he'd move on to the next person
I mean I could just make a conjecture
right here and now and it could be
called the Brady Haran conjecture but
that's not really allowed what
credibility does a conjecture have to
have before it's really a conjecture I
think you have to probably demonstrate
that it's it's held in lots and lots and
lots of situations where it might fall
down and that it's it's survived all of
the possible obvious tests that you can
make but of course we can't we can't
test this up to infinite number of
numbers so it would actually need a
formal proof for it to work